welcome to architecting startups with
google cloud a series where we showcase
the latest and greatest startup
customers and how they're architecting
and deploying their production ready
workloads on gcp
my name is vicola and today i'm pleased
to introduce the cto of band protocol
sorowit
today we'll learn about how band
protocol builds with google cloud and
how they are working to improve
traditional blockchain technology
yeah so hi bukola i'm excited to be here
and looking forward to demystifying
blockchain and how we advance protocol
architect our solution on google cloud
thanks swit for joining us
let's lay the foundation for those who
are new to blockchain could you help our
audience understand what a blockchain is
sure
in a nutshell a blockchain is a
distributed database that anyone can own
the data and has logic to make sure that
everyone sees the same truth
so a blockchain system has three main
properties immutability trustlessness
and also censorship resistance
so immutable is when something is
recorded and finalized on the blockchain
is practically impossible to be changed
as the second property is trustless this
is when there's no centralized party in
which anyone has to trust to maintain
the blockchain data
and the third property is censorship
resistance
which is a property that anyone can
always interact with a public blockchain
without any restriction
awesome so now that we understand what a
blockchain is could you tell us about
band protocol and how it contributes to
the web3 ecosystem
yeah so so blockchains are very great at
providing immutable storage and
deterministic verifiable computations
however they fall short when it comes to
trusted real-world information available
outside of the network
so band protocol enhances smart
contracts functionalities by granting
them access to reliable data without any
central authority or point of failure
so the foundation of bamboo call is
benching which is a high-performing
blockchain built specifically for data
oracle
it is designed to be compatible with all
existing smart contract platforms
available in the market and
any framework
so in a trustless and decentralized
manner a band protocol does the heavy
lifting job of pulling data from the
external sources aggregating and
packaging the data into the format that
is very easy to consume at the
application level and also
cryptographically verifies the identity
of data across multiple blockchains
could you go into more detail on what a
data oracle is and maybe give us some
examples of real world use cases of the
protocol
so yeah the the majority of
decentralized applications on public
blockchains need external data
as it is a very essential part of the
services for example a lending protocol
must be able to access reliable real
world assets prices to calculate how
much a user can borrow given collateral
a band protocol tackles this problem by
creating a crisis oracle that anyone can
verify where the data origin is from
the protocol also has economic incentive
currency
that provided information is correct and
protected from manipulations by
malicious actors
so here are the four key actors in the
band ecosystem
so the first part is data consumer which
are the applications that rely on
off-chain data
the second part is validators who are
the one running the banshee network and
getting data from outside to the
blockchain
the third part is data providers this
could be institutions or exchanges that
are providing raw data that the
validators can fetch and respond to
oracle requests
and the fourth
actor is the token speakers who are
very essential to the mention because
they speak ban tokens to signal
validators and also secure data
correctness
so without ban protocol application
developers
without ban protocol application
developers are required to trust
centralized parties to provide price
data for the application
and this would essentially become a
centralized component which somewhat
contradicts the purpose of building on
the blockchain and in addition it also
creates a single point of failure and
adds more risk to the application itself
so now that we understand more about the
data oracle let's get into the technical
details how does the band chain work how
does band protocol leverage gcp
technologies in bandchain system
so at band protocol not only do we build
software that anyone can run to operate
as a decentralized node of band chain
but we also provide end-to-end oracle
integration service that that's our
heavy lifting job
for our clients
so although bank chain is public and
open blockchain anyone can operate when
it comes to ecosystem and integration
tools we have been heavily elaborating
the support of gcp and infrastructure
so let me quickly walk you through a few
components that we do quickly
so the first component is the public ps
gce which are the set of mentioned
instances that we operate to make sure
that validators can communicate with one
another
and these public peers also help the
newly joining nodes to find up-to-date
peers and syncs blockchain data quickly
the second component is the public rest
endpoint which is a set of instances
that we use publicly for sending
transactions and curing state on band
chain
with the use of gce load balancers and
instance group we are able to ensure
that we can handle all the requests even
when under heavy load
a managed instance group for internal
use is another group that is quite
similar to the previous one but this
group is used internally to ensure that
our critical product such as our
flagship standard data set are not
interrupted
we have cosmos scan which is a block
explorer backed by our spatial node for
tracking and saving the blockchain state
into a sql database and service for
curing data to show on our block
explorer website and cosmos standard io
and the last component is band standard
data set which is a software system that
is built with several gcp tools
including gce the cloud function the
class c code the secret manager
and they are all work together to
publish data from band chain to other
public blockchains
so you mentioned quite a few
gcp technologies that band protocol
leverages
maybe we can dive into how band chain
uses compute engine
yeah so
let's step back a little bit so as a b2b
service provider
we want to stress that the reliability
of our tech deployment is very important
as we are securing more than 10 billion
of total value
at the peak times for our clients and
here's how we do it
so currently we run multiple benching
nodes ourselves to serve as a foundation
for band chain to ensure that mention
can operate very smoothly during this
early phase
each node runs using its own compute
engine instance
we also operate a few additional
mentioned nodes to serve as the endpoint
for query and send transaction on
benching network and these nodes
runs on compute engine as instance group
used
using the cloud load balancer
the compute engine also allows us to
easily monitor the cpu consumption the
memory the disk utilization via
notification
and with a proper monitoring analyst
system we are able to promptly bring the
nodes back online in the event of any
downtime due to cpu or memory spike
so what is the request pattern on these
nodes
yeah so on average we see around 500 000
requests per day which means that we
really need to have auto scaling with
the instance groups
so with regards to the instance that
rick said that that received request
publicly we are setting up multiple
instances group in various regions and a
load balancer in front of this group for
routing requests based on ips
we also use auto scaling within each
group to make sure that we can handle
requests at any given time especially
during contestion so let's switch the
topic a little bit and how is the data
pushed to other blockchains for
developers to use yeah so at band
protocol we implemented a price feed
service that allows users to request
price from band chain and relay the
result to the target smart contract
we designed this service
using several micro services to make
them very easy to maintain and
communicate uh specifically using cloud
pub sub mechanism as the communication
platform between the services
and this is a lot better option than the
polling that we did previously because
it reduces a lot of latency between
different services while also making the
system more robust and independent from
each other
we also utilize the secret manager for
our transaction signer to manage the
private key before signing a transaction
and broadcasting transaction to
different target blockchains and this is
to ensure that only authorized services
will ever have access to the private
keys
and you mentioned earlier that your team
uses cloud sql could you speak on why
you chose cloud sql specifically over
other database offerings
yeah so due to our data pattern on the
block explorer the sql database is the
most suitable solution because it allows
us to define the tables and schema to
store data
define relations between table to
generate graphql provided service that
hosts our blog explorer and to create
indices that optimize security that we
often use
and using cloud sql is also better for
us in terms of resource management
security
maintenance and monitoring compared to
using other services
and we talked offline about how band
protocol has worked directly with
members of the gcp team i feel like this
could be valuable for our audience so
could you share more about that yeah
this is something that i really like so
so we certainly do have a regular
catch-ups with gcps uh monthly right now
and
actually recently we hosted a workshop
with gcp team to discuss the ways we can
improve the infrastructure further
together and because the gcp team is
very familiar with the context and then
understands the objective of our
technology they can offer a lot of great
advice so the gcp team has helped us
understand the tools that we could
leverage and the possible ways we can
architect our infrastructure and i'm
really excited for what's more to come
thank you so much swift for joining us
today where can our audience go to learn
more about band protocol yeah so for
more information about band protocol you
can visit our main website
bamboo.com and there you can also find
out how to reach us on other social
network platforms ranging from our
twitter our telegram medium discord
where you can get the latest news and
update of our recent projects and
partnerships
and furthermore you can also find more
information of our current products such
as our band standard data set
block explorer cosmos scan as well as
the list of our growing partners
at our ecosystem tool called
bandpartners.io
thanks again swift for joining us for
this episode we learned so much about
how band protocol is improving
blockchain by being a middle layer
providing reliable data to decentralized
applications we also learned how they
use google cloud to build the solution
if you enjoyed this video series please
make sure to click the like and the
subscribe button and we'll see you next
time